[Musique]
bonjour ça va bien ouais ça va bien et
au lierse et moi aussi donc bonjour tout
le monde
mais aujourd'hui vient parler du
secondaire donc ce jour-là ce haut lieu
de formation des futurs citoyens restent
pour faire des citoyens responsables
nous préparer à la vraie vie on hésite
depuis que je suis à l'école ce qui est
à dire en prématernelle mémoire à penser
que c'est vraiment important que
j'apprenne à compter jusqu'à 10 en
espagnol quand j'avais 4 ans fait
qu'amener à la prématernelle puis depuis
le premier jour que je rentrais là j'ai
toujours un peu chiant les là dessus
puis cholet pose sur la durée d co sur
les pose sur le fait que je m'entendais
pas avec mes professeurs ou avec mes
amis d'école
je suis allé sur le fait que ce que
jusqu'à j'apprenais je crois pas que
c'était assez concret piqûre la vente
jeudi bon notre dirigeant bien eu viol
et sur l'école c'est pas du tout le cas
je suis vraiment l'importance que ça lui
l'école si on apprend à vivre en société
on apprend à respecter l'autorité les
règles
tous ces titres est important de
reconnaître notre histoire puis
d'élargir nos horizons avec le cr que
les autres religions mais je pense
vraiment que des grosses lacunes dans
notre système d'éducation
à commencer par le fait de c'est quoi le
but du secondaire selon moi le second
mandat c'est un endroit où est ce qu'on
doit faire une formation générale pour
se préparer à la vie la vraie vie ou
est-ce qu'on doit former des citoyens
responsables
pis ce qu'on apprend à l'école sa rente
pont en lien avec celui là je crois que
on manque une énorme opportunité avec ce
qu'on fait maintenant on a l'opportunité
d'avoir toute l'histoire demain au même
endroit cinq jours par semaine pendant
cinq ans qu'est ce qu'on fait on leur
apprend juste des choses théorique des
choses que rarement on va se le dire
l'un à moins que si vous disiez genre
chaque jour les fonctions de support
données relatives
personnellement moi est oui souvent donc
vraiment je pense que c'est important de
se concentrer sur le but là il ya plein
de gens qui disent ainsi quoi tu avoir
une indication comme nos grands parents
juste qu'on créac'h trône à coups de
pierres à faire de la bouffe en partie -
si j'avais le contrôle de sa musique à
sion
je changerais c'est vraiment se
concentrer sur le vrai but incapable que
quand les gens ils sortent du secondaire
ils savent comment vivent
pipeau bien comment faire de la bouffe
comment réparer ton choix mais comment
vivre comment être heureux
comment atteindre début comment bien
pareil dans une entrevue
comment rester motivé par toi même comme
avoir des relations harmonieuses
puiqu'il question pas plus du côté
pratique je parlerai justement aussi de
comment se faire à un repos avec moins
d'argent
comment est ce qu'on fait pour justement
bien varié dans une entrevue tout sur le
secourisme le secourisme tout le monde
sait ou des eaux a déjà appris en un
conflit oublié ce moment comment
calculer l'heure d'une soir mais il ya
quelqu'un est en train de crever à côté
de vous autres god locmane on sait pas
des choses aussi importantes que ce que
je peux ça fait deux sens à vos yeux le
rayonnement qui disent que c'est le rôle
des parents face à d'enseigner aux
élèves à l'hiver comme la revue via bien
vivre tout ça mais on paie des jeux
chacun d'entre vous payent leurs impôts
d'or leurs salaires qui comme eux mêmes
pour payer des gens pour enseigner aux
jeunes à vivre quelques traits pour la
vraie vie pourquoi est-ce qu'on
profiterait pas de cette opportunité là
incroyable
sinon j'aimerais vous parler d'injustice
fidèles différence là c'est sûr que ça
verichip d'arriver à une éducation puis
genre c'est injuste mais c'est pas du
tout le point
il ya beaucoup de gens sûrement vous
avez capable de vous rappeler de cancer
tôt à vous qui trouvent que le mettez
vous dans la peau d'un étudiant là quand
ils vont à l'école pluie il va juste
parce qu'il sait qu'au bout de 20
secondes pour que fait savoir une job
plus temps mais lui il voit passer tous
comme une opportunité voici comme une
obligation
il faut comme dans l'temps ou est-ce
qu'on fait envoyer une personne sur cent
à l'école c'est rendu que pour juste
pour dire qu'on est capable d'être une
civilisation et du qui on va racheter
n'importe quoi dans le système pour dire
quand on apprend des choses alors que je
crois pas que c'est du bourrage de crâne
qu'on a fait chaque personnage il si son
temps libre pour apprendre sur les
choses qui la fait vibrer avait peint
sur une étoile avec l'ancien business
men on doit tout le temps sacrifice
autant le libre lycée but pour
travailler sur des choses qui est la
halle 6 a observé al arich egypte a fait
ses devoirs sur la formule quadratique
plc que jamais le sujet
mais elle fait juste parce que c'est
obligé obliger ce sacré un grossissement
de parler ce n'est aujourd'hui plus rien
faire par rapport à ça imaginez si cette
personne là à savais que tout ce qui a
fait présentement ça va observer tout de
suite allé à serais content d'aller à
l'école avait reçu comme une opportunité
ce serait pas comme du temps perdu après
ce on vient se demander pourquoi ce que
les jeunes décrochent publie les excuses
batteur du ministère comme la situation
socio économique
le vrai problème pourquoi ce que les
jeunes décrochent c'est parce que le but
d'avoir un diplôme c'est pas assez pour
eux ils doivent avoir quelque chose qui
les prend qui arrivent à l'école si
aujourd'hui ça va servir que j'aime ici
ça c'est mon opinion à moi puis je sais
que c'est sûr que c'est une exagération
sais si je parle beaucoup là mais il ya
vraiment du monde que hôte ils viennent
ils viennent le juste parce que c'est
pour sopi dans le fond je pense vraiment
que si on a l'opportunité d'améliorer
quelque chose pourquoi est ce qu'on
pensait a contredit harper pour une
telle personne est mort c'est pas si
pire que ça
mais si on a l'opportunité de la rangée
il faut qu'on sorte de sucre qu on la
range parce que beaucoup de faux pas qui
ont été faites en restant immobile
bon je m'appelle jean lacoste est rien
puis toute ma vie j'ai pas été capable
de dire quelque chose qui fait pas mon
affaire je m'assois plus de rien chacun
ses qualités chacun ses défauts ça c'est
la mienne dit moi je peux juste pas
m'asseoir puisse dire justement je suis
allé là dessus que je fasse rien je fais
des conférences dans les écoles sur le
succès
qu'est ce que je leur dis tout le temps
c'est de se contenter sur quoi ils ont
le pouvoir
dis moi c'est sur cela que j'ai le
pouvoir je demande pas faire une réforme
parce que l'on sait la dernière ça c'est
parce que ma vie pensez donc je demande
pas du tout quelque chose de radical
c'est vraiment que ce soit arrachée d'un
cursus qu'on commence à penser à
préparer pour la vie qui soit sous forme
de capsules de 15 minutes par jour ou un
cours d'une heure par semaine juste
d'inculquer le fait d'apprendre aux
jeunes à se préparer à la vie moi j'ai
pensé que le vrai le maire - de
remplacer par une pétition
donc qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
commencé par avoir la réaction de mon
école puis j'ai commencé avec avec ça
j'ai fait j'ai vraiment j'en ressors
remercier sim écoute les actions l'école
de m'avoir permis d'avoir fait ça a été
vraiment incroyable c'est du
gouvernement lancé
95% des gens à qui j'ai parlé de mon
projet j'ai passé dans l'équipe
ont signé la pétition ensuite j'ai lancé
ma page facebook en deux semaines du 8
181 x après ce gp on a parlé moins d'un
journal local puis ensuite sur la salle
commençait à ce prêtre j'étais dans les
médias au show de martino puis j'ai eu
incroyable match support autant de mes
professeurs qui mena musique c'est vrai
ce que je disais autant que des gens qui
n'importe qui qui venaient me parler me
disais ouais t'as raison que j'aimerais
ça va pouvoir participer au jus de
l'argent d'entrepreneurs de policiers
rita des 106
le ministre de l'éducation m'ont donné
d'argent c'est vraiment quelque chose
puisque les gens accrochent puis je
pense que c'est justement le fait que
tout le monde est toujours pensé surtout
bon mais que maintenant c'est la gageure
que maintenant le mouvement parti qu'on
peut rentrer là dedans puis justement si
c'est que tout le monde pensait tout
bord puis maintenant on met en action
je suis justement pour ça que j'ai lancé
le mouvement art danse et le mouvement
pour l'autonomie et la
responsabilisation des étudiants de
notre temps j'ai avec déjà six ans d'âge
je sais que je suis là sur la salle
maintenant mais je sais grâce à trois
personnes extraordinaires dont julien
eybert alexis briller langevin et nina
mature merci beaucoup vous êtes super
puis c'est vraiment on est parti ce
qu'on veut vraiment aller jusqu'au bout
donc bientôt il va y avoir une pétition
en ligne doit se ferait vous pouvez
venir signer puis vraiment je vous en
prie venez signer pour vous pour les
personnes qui ont peu le temps du qui
ont peu la chance avant pis pour les
personnes que vous revenez après vous
parce que c'est pas du tout une question
de chômage à de la séance non c'est une
question de se forger la société de
demain puis bien la forge et pour aller
vers l'humanité merci beaucoup tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]